[Musique]
c'est bel et bien permis pour les
enquêteurs de prétendre être une
adolescente qui offre des services
sexuels sur internet pour piéger des
pédophiles c'est la course suprême qui a
validé la technique d'enquête la semaine
dernière dans 4 jugements le stade des
causes qui concernait quatre hommes de
la région de York en Ontario les quatre
accusés prétendaient qu'il avait qu'ils
avaient été victime de provocation
policière alors pour en parler en juin
maître Geneviève Bodet elle est
procureur au DPCP bonjour maître Bodin
bonjour madame ricin alors dans une des
causes le juge du procès lui il avait
conclu bel et bien que l'accusé avait
fait l'objet de provocation policière
c'est-à-dire qu'on lui avait on lui
avait presque incité à commettre un
crime on lui avait offert cette occasion
là la Cour suprême dit que ça n'en
n'était pas de la provocation alors
définissez-nous ce que c'est que la
provocation policière
oui en fait la provocation policière
c'est lorsque l'État va donner
l'occasion à un individu de comète une
infraction criminelle ce qu'on voit le
plus souvent au niveau de la provocation
policière c'est notamment dans les
dossiers en matière de trafic de
stupéfiant quand les policiers vont
utiliser un agent infiltration pour
aller acheter une certaine quantité à ce
moment-là de
stupéfiants donc ils vont utiliser un
agent de l'État qui va se faire penser
pour un acheteur et tout ça pour amasser
de la preuve pour pouvoir incriminer à
ce moment-là le vendeur donc c'est
l'État qui donne l'occasion à l'accusé
au suspect de commettre une infraction
une infraction qu'il n'aurait pas
commise autrement ou une infection qui
aurait commise de toute façon
bien entendu c'est une infraction qui
aurait commise de toute façon parce que
les policiers peuvent pas choisir
quelqu'un au hasard le fait pas se
promener dans la rue poser à n'importe
qui à ce moment-là d'acheter des
stupéfiants ils doivent avoir des
soupçons raisonnables pour viser une
personne en particulier ou encore il
faut que ce soit dans le cadre d'une
véritable enquête en matière de
proxénétisme ben c'est là qu'on tombe
dans les véritables enquêtes c'est de
dire il y a une problématique dans des
régions bien précises ou des proxénètes
vont vendre des services sexuels de
jeunes mineurs et pour faire face à
cette problématique là qu'on va enquêter
qu'on va détailler qu'on va venir
appuyer par des faits les policiers vont
pouvoir utiliser à ce moment-là un agent
d'infiltration dans le cadre de leurs
enquêtes évidemment dans ce cas-ci le
sept ans qui s'appelait le projet
Raphaël il s'agissait d'une enquête en
ligne forcément c'est des histoires sur
internet alors est-ce qu'on fait une
distinction entre une enquête virtuelle
donc en ligne et une enquête qui se
déroule dans la vraie vie dans un
véritable espace physique
c'est sûr que c'est différent parce que
un endroit physique on va être capable
de le déterminer avec précision c'est
dans cette décision là du projet Raphaël
on faisait beaucoup état d'un dossier
qui était similaire où on visait un
certain pâté de 6 rue alors c'est facile
on vit ici quand on parle d'Internet ben
internet on le sait c'est excessivement
l'air ça l'une portée qui est très très
grande donc oui on fait une distinction
mais ce qu'on vient nous dire c'est que
étant donné qu'Internet c'est plus
difficile de cibler des endroits précis
mais il va falloir viser à ce moment-là
des particularités au niveau notamment
des applications ou des sites internet
et c'est ça qu'on a réussi à faire dans
le projet Raphaël c'est pas juste sur
internet en général le site en
particulier
oui exactement les policiers les
connaissent c'est cette loi c'est des
sites comme je vous parle de la
véritable enquête c'est détaillé c'est
enquêté on met pas ça par exemple sur
Facebook de manière générale dans le
projet Raphaël c'était un site qui était
ciblé mais c'est en plus une
sous-catégorie d'annonces donc on avait
défini cet endroit-là avec assez de
précision selon la cour suprême pour que
ça ne soit pas de la provocation
policière exacte et je me dis que dans
le contexte actuel alors qu'on essaie de
lutter le mieux qu'on peut contre la
pornographie juvénile l'exploitation
sexuelle de mineurs on peut dire que
c'est une bonne nouvelle que cette
technique d'enquête soit validée
tout à fait on était très très heureux
de la décision de la Cour suprême
les suspects les accusés là utilisent
des moyens de plus en plus
de plus en plus poussés pour commettre
leurs infractions donc il faut qu'on
puisse donner à nos policiers des
méthodes pour leur permettre d'aller
combattre ces infractions-là en matière
de proxénétisme on va pas afficher des
annonces sur internet qui cibles
directement des jeunes féminins donc il
faut être capable de combattre ça avec
des moyens réels des moyens concrets
puis la Cour suprême est venue de zéro
policier ben vous pouvez le faire est-ce
que ça peut changer les choses par
exemple élargir les façons d'enquêter ou
même les possibilités de faire des
poursuites pour le DPC puis qu'est-ce
que ça change le fait que la course
prime est confirmée cette façon
d'enquêter
c'est sûr que on voit de plus en plus en
fait dans les rapports là qui ont été
faits par le gouvernement on demande
même au corps policier de faire ce qu'on
appelle des opérations clients parce que
c'est ça le dossier Raphaël c'est de
mettre une annonce sur Internet où on va
aller viser le client donc les policiers
c'est un moyen d'enquête qui a été
démontré comme étant très très efficace
donc d'avoir la validation de la course
suprême pour nous dire vous pouvez faire
ce type d'enquête là et ça ne pourra
plus être contesté ou considéré comme de
la provocation policière mais ça va
pouvoir faire en sorte que les dossiers
vont pouvoir peut-être se régler plus
rapidement mais augmenter également le
nombre de corps politiques qui vont
pouvoir utiliser ces méthodes d'enquête
là bon alors c'est une bonne nouvelle
tout le monde peut s'en servir enfin
abonnés
du DPCP merci infiniment de nous avoir
parlé
ça m'a fait plaisir au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI